حياكم الله اكد الزعماء والمشاركون في قمه
مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون والشراكه المنعقد
بمنطقه البحر الميت في الاردن لوقوف في
الوقوف الى جوار العراق وعلى اهميه العمل
الجماعي لمواجهه التحديات وقال العهد
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني في كلمه
افتتاحيه ان مواجهه التحديات المشتركه
التي تواجه المنطقه تستدعي عملا جماعيا
مشددا على حاجه المنطقه للاستقرار والسلام
العادل والتعاون الاقليمي من جانبه على
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد الشيعه
السوداني ان المؤتمر ينعقد من اجل خدمه
المصالح المشتركه لضمان امن العراق
واستقراره مؤكدا رفض بلاده لاي تدخل
بشؤونها الداخليه او اي مساسا بسيادتها
اما وزير الخارجيه الايراني امير عبد الله
هيام فقال ان الحوار والتعاون بين دول
الاقليم ليس خيارا بل هو ضروره ملحه
وانستغرام اروى هدوء ايران يرتبط باستقرار
وامن المنطقه مؤكد ان موقف ايران ثابت
بالحفاظ على سلميه برنامجها النووي ولن
تغيره هذا الموقف وافقا قوله ايران
اكدت على استعداد ايران لاستئناف
المحادثات بشان ملفها النووي والوصول الى
الخطوات النهائيه لابرام الاتفاق النووي
مع مراعاه الخطوط الحمراء والنصوص المقدمه
من قبلنا وان تتعامل الدول الاخرى بواقعيه
اكثر
[موسيقى]
معنى من واشنطن الباحث في الشان الايرانيه
الدكتور حسن هاشميان ومن عمان المحلل
السياسي العراقيه الدكتور باسل حسين ليبدا
اولا من واشنطن مع الدكتور حسن دكتور حسن
يعني ايران تتحدث عن الحاجه الى الاستقرار
والعوده الى المحيط الاقليمي والدولي عوده
ايران هذه المره او النيه هي مراوغه ام
حاجه وضروره ملحها في هذا الوقت
نعم تحيه لكم ولو ضيف الكريم ومشاهد
العربيه انا اعتقد كلام عبد الله ايام
وتصريحاته معارض تماما مع الواقع على
الاقل على صعيدين صعيدي الملف النووي وصل
عيد تدخلاتها في المنطقه وداعا المليشيات
هناك ازمه كبيره الان تجري في موضوع الملف
النووي في تعاون النظام الايراني مع
الوكاله وايضا تطبيق هذه السياسه النوويه
مع مطالب الجيران وما يطلبه الجيران من
خلال التصريحات السلميه والمطالب السلميه
ايضا الدعم للمليشيات مستمر نشهده في
العراق في اليمن في لبنان في مكانات اخرى
ولكن بتقدير لنا هذا الموضوع الان هو ياتي
في ظرف حساس جدا ايران الان تعاني بشكل
اكبر من عزله خانقه اكبر كانت عليه في
السابق يعني هناك ازمه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي نرى مثلا النمس
والنمسا هي معروفه بعلاقاتها الطيبه معها
النظام الايراني ولكن نرى النمس مجموع
اعضاء البرلمان يتكفلون بالسجناء في داخل
ايران هذه يعني ازمه كبيره مع النظام
الايراني ولكن يعني عبد الله قال بان
التاكيد على سلميه البرنامج النووي
الايراني وبالتالي لا يريد ان يغلق هذا
الباب بوجه المجتمع الدولي
هذا هو
مفارقه مفارقه كبيره يعني ما يقوم به من
اعمال هذا النظام وما يصرح عبد الله ايانه
او اي مسؤول ايراني ولكن انا بتقديري هذه
المره وخاصه بعد المظاهرات والثوره
المستمره في داخل ايران حقيقه النظام
الايراني مسطر لمعالجه اموره مع الدول
الجوار مصدر ايضا لمعالجه الملف النووي مع
الوكاله ومع المجتمع الدولي ولذلك انا
اعتقد المباراه والاحتجاجات والثوره
الجاريه مشكله بطن جدا كبيرا على هذا
النظام حتى ياتي بهذه الوضع ويرى هذه
الوضعيات بان لا يمكن حل القضيه الجاريه
الان في داخل الان الا مثلا حل موضوع
الاشياء والتفاهم مع الدول الجوار لان هذا
هو بالاساس مطلق الشعب الايراني الشعب
الايراني لا يريد تدخلات في المنطقه وغيره
طيب الى عمان المحلل السياسي العراقيه
دكتور باسل الحسين يعني اذا اتفقنا ان ما
يدعو ايران الى مد اا يد التعاون هذه
المره والحاجه الى استقرار ايران هو حاجه
الى استقرار المنطقه كما اشار عبد الله
هيان هل اليوم نستطيع ان نقول بان هذه
اليد الممدوده هي بالفعل نحو خطوه جديده
ام انه الواقع الذي تعيشه ايران همم هو
فقط يريد ان يمضي الى الامام حتى تتحل
المشاكل في الداخل الايراني وبالتالي
العوده الى ما كنا عليه
مثل مساء الخير سيدي الكريم ولا مشاهدكم
كرامه
الواقع يشي بشيء اخر حقيقي
اليد الممدوده ينبغي ان يعني يتم بافعال
همم
اقول مثل المصري اسمع كلامك اصدق افعالك
حقيقه لانه
هنالك مفارقه ما بين هذا الادعاء ومن بين
السلوك الفعلي ايران تعاني من ازمه داخليه
كبيره
تصاعد حركه الاحتجاج الداخلي وايضا لديها
ازمه مع الخارج مع محيطها مع محيطها
الاقليمي وايضا مع المحيط الدولي وبالتالي
هذا النظام الايراني يجد نفسه ولذلك يعني
يحاول تنفس عبر هذه المؤتمرات ارسال رساله
فيعني على الاقل يركز بجبهه واحده
هذه دكتور باسل همم
صحيح لكن مشكله المحيط نتكلم العرب تحديدا
مشكلتهم ليس مع ايران الدوله
مشكلتهم ليس مع ايران الدوله مشكلتهم مع
عيران الثوره وهذا هو يعني مبعث الخطا
لانه ايران تتصرف الجديد اتصرف مع الدول
العربيه هي ايران الثوره وليس ايران
الدوله الدول العربيه لا مانع لديها من
التعامل مع ايران الدوله لكنه بالتاكيد لن
ترحب بايران الثوره وتصدير الثوره
الايرانيه وتصدم لي شياط وتصدير السلاح
وتصدير وفخاخات وتصدير الطائرات المسير
هذه ايران الثوره لا يمكن هذه همم تكون يد
ممدوده هذه
العبث وبالتالي ما نريد اليد الممدوده ان
تكون بالفعل علاقات حسن الجوار احترام
القانون الدولي عدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه هل ايران تفعل ذلك ولذلك يقول
الكلام عكس السلوك الايراني ينبغي تعديل
السلوك ولذلك كان هذا المطلب الاساسي
المطلب الاساسي من محيط الاقليمي المطلب
الاساسي من المحيط الدولي ان تعدل ايران
سلوكها ولا طالما قال المجتمع الدولي بذلك
نحن نريد بنيران ان تعدل سلوكها لكن هل
ايران مستعده فعلا ان تعدل سلوكها حينما
يرى الدول الجوله العربي ذلك بالتاكيد سوف
تعدل سلوكا يتذكر في عام 2000 حينما كان
همم الخاتم وصل المعتدلون توصلنا الى
الاتفاقيه الامنيه ما بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وايران لانه كان خط معتدل اذن مشكله ليس
العرب المشكله ايرانيه حينما تصعد التشدد
بالتاكيد ما الذي يمكن ان يتصرف العرب
تجاهه يطرح نفسه
حكومه جديده ايضا
لا زالت مجرد ادعاءات لم نرى افعال المهم
هي الافعال وليست الاقوال هل الافعال
بالفعل تشي باليد الممدوده ان اقول لك على
الاطلاق كلا لا ليس هنالك من تصرف ايراني
حقيقي يشيل انه ايران حارس على استقرار
المنطقه الكل يرحب باتفاق اقليمي امني
ممكن نظام اقليم ان يشمل الجميع ان يؤذي
الاستقرار لكن ايران المشكله يعني دائما
ما كانت تصدر ازماتها سواء العراق لبنان
سوريا اليمني الى اخره وبالتالي كانت عام
الاستقرار وليس همم عدم استقرار وليس عدم
خلينا ننتقل الى ال- ال- المقلب الاخر في
العراق همم السوداني قال
بانئي عن نفسه همم اصطفاء في المحاور
الدائر واجواء التصعيد ما الذي يقصد اذا
كان همم يعني الكاظمي السابق كان يقصد عدم
التدخل من قبل وكان واضحا في ذلك اكثر من
مره هذه المره وهذه اول همم يعني اول
مؤتمر همم يكون به رئيس الوزراء العراقي
من يقصد ماذا يقصد بالناي عن همم بالناي
بالنفس عن المحاور محاور التصعيد
ويحاول ان يعني يرسل رساله لان حكومتي سوف
تقوم على استمرار علاقه التوازن التي
بناها الكاظمي وانا اعتقد هذا صعب جدا انه
ندرك جميعا ان همم كاظم همم بنى سياسه
متوازنه حقيقه ونجح فيها لكن هو همم
السوداني اشكرك لانه من يثير السوداني او
من يؤثر عليه الاطار بالتالي هو قالها هذه
حكومه اطاره وبتعلم كم العلاقه العضويه ما
بين الاطار
وايران حجم المبادلات اقتصاديه المطروحه
تشيء انها العراق سيكون جزيره معزول الذي
ايران همم
الهيكله الحكومه بناء على الرغبات
الايرانيه ايضا يشيل ان همم ليست هناك
سياسه نيء بالتكيس يكون التاثير الايراني
كبير جدا حينما تفرض ايران ارادتها على
تشكيل الحكومه وعلى
تاثير الحكومه ثم تضع حتى في وزاره النفط
ممثلين لها في داخل وزاره النفط هذه ليست
هنا لكن طيب بمعنى هنالك علاقه التبعيه
وهذا ما نخشى ان يتحول العراق في هذه
الفتره ان يكون يعني حديقه خلفيه سياسي او
مكب النفايات لسياس الخارجيه الايرانيه
وهذا حقيقه ما يخشاه كثير في العراق طيب
دكتور حسن هل ايران هي ما زالت قادره على
جعل العراق حديقه خلفيه لها هل همم اليوم
هذه الحكومه الجديده الا تستطيع فك
الارتباط وان كان الاطار التنسيقي هو من
يسير
انا اللي اعتقد ان هذه الحكومه الجديده في
العراق تستطيع الناي عن النفس والابتعاد
عن المحور الايراني كما تفضل الضيف هذه
الحكومه هي مدعومه من الميليشيات التابعه
للحراسات الثوري ولذلك سيطرت ايران واضحه
وايضا سيطرت ايران من خلال تشكيلات كان
واضح وهناك زيارات مكوكيه كانت لقائد
القدس اسماعيل اغاني
انا اعتقد ان لو مثلا راينا موقف مهم
وواضح من هذه الحكومه في العراق في زمن
الهجوم على اربيل هناك كم مره الحرس
الثوري هاجم اربيل وانتهك السياده
العراقيه ولكن لم نرى اي موقف قوي من هذه
الحكومه ولا اعتقد ان هذه الحكومه تريد
تتخذ موقف قوي اتجاه هذا همم هذه الحملات
والحرس الثوري بالمستقبل ايضا بها رياحيه
سيقوم بهذه الانتهاكات لذلك انا لا اعتقد
ان هناك مؤشر واضح اولا بان الحكومه
الحاليه في العراق منفصله على الحركه يعني
واكد على رفض بلاده تدخل بشؤونها من اي
دوله من دول الجوار حتى يعني ايراني يقصد
بالتالي ايضا
نحن لا نخدع انفسنا المؤتمر التي قام في
الاردن المملكه الاردنيه
اسبابه كانت 90% متعلقه بايران يعني هل
هناك المملكه العربيه السعوديه تزعزع
الاستمرار في المنطقه او مصر تزعزع
الاستمرار في منطقه الاستقرار في
المنطميه ايران وعشره بالميه لتركيا لذلك
الان كل شيء كان موجه الى النظام الايراني
ان يعيد حساباته ويعيش سياساته وبالتاكيد
ان لا نرى ان هناك مؤشر طبعا هناك تصريحات
ولكن لا نرى مؤشر حقيقي وواضعي من قبل هذا
النظام بتغيير السياسيته في المنطقه
توافق راي الدكتور حسن يعني حوار الطرشان
اذا كان اذا جاز التعبير ام انه هناك صدا
يسمع من خلال هكذا مؤتمر قد تغير ايران من
سياساتها وموقعها وان كان اجباره او
اضطراره
اتفقت تماما اتفق تماما مع تفاضل به
دكتوره حسن من صعوبه
يعني تصور ان ايران ممكن تعدل ايران لديها
مشروع للهيمنه وبالتالي هي ترى العراق
مجال حيوي لتنفيذ هذه السياسه والمشروع
الهيمنه ثم التمدد عبر العراق عبر سوريا
ثم لبنان كاحد خطوط
الهيمنه همم لا اعتقد ان ايران مستعده ان
تضحي بذلك في سبيل الاستقرار المنطقه
وستبقى ايران عامل اساسي لزعزعه استقرار
همم المنطقه هذا النظام حقيقه يعني مع
الاسف لا يدرك اهميه الاستقرار المنطقه
يعني مؤتمر بغداد
دكتور باسل
في الجانب الايراني لا اعتقد يعني ربما في
الجوانب الاخرى عمليه الربط الكهربائي مع
مجلس التعاون مع مصر والاردن والكهرباء
هذه عوامل استقرار ممكن انه تستفاد منها
لكن
نعلم جيدا حجم التاثير الايراني وكيفيه
ساهمت ايران في زعزعه الاستقرار وعدم
الاستقرار وتاثيرها ودعم الميليشيات
والسلاح والى اخر وانشاء دوله موازيه
ايران لا تفضل التعامل مع العراق دوله
تفضل التعامل مع المليشيات الموازيه
للدوله وهذا هو من الخطر قلت لاحظ في كل
دول النزاع في الدول العربيه لا تفضل
التعامل مع الدول تفضل التعامل مع الدوله
الموازيه الميليشيات كل الدول انظر في
لبنان
فقط التعامل مع الدوله
الايجابيه كالربطه الكهربائي والدعم
العربي وغيرها من دول الجوار الا تعطي
الحكومه العراقيه القدره على فك هذا
الارتباط انجاز التعبير عيران
بالتاكيد تعطي القدره اذا ارادت هذه
الحكومه ولكن مع الاسف هذه الحكومه مرتبطه
بشكل ايدولوجي وعضوي مع النظام الايراني
وعذاب السوداني يريد فصل العراق عن النظام
الايراني والضغوطاته يجب ابعاد المليشيات
الدوله العراقيه هذه مثلا مهمه المساله
الاخرى
ان النظام الايراني هو نظام رجيم عندما
يقوم همم يعني الضغط عليه
والاخذ الاوراق من يدي لان ضغط الداخلي
الى الحركه الداخلي وورقه جدا مهمه واخذت
اوراق كثيره من هذا النظام ولذلك باعتقادي
يسعى
الامتداد وهمم الصلح مع الجوع شكرا جزيلا
للباحث في الشان الايراني الدكتور حسن
هاشميان والشكر موصول للمحلل السياسي
العراقي الدكتور باسل حسين من عمان شكرا
جزيلا لكم ضيفيه الكريمين
شكرا لكم بالمتابعه المزيد مع الزملاء في
نشراتنا الى اللقاء